I was saying that um I got so much
positive uplifting feedback from the
first interview it was great
it was great and that's really really
um springboarded me and to stand willing
you know to continue to move forward
I look at it every day or either almost
every other day
you were keeping inside for a long time
yeah that just makes the problem
yeah stubborn right uh-huh you got you
gotta free yourself man
you gotta I had to
stop um
wanted to feel embarrassed stop me from
living my life and sexual abuse is
humiliating right oh man it's a shame
I really can't describe it man it's just
um it's unhinging
it changes everything
it gives you trust issues
you know
um all kind of different things
know um
but I've grown
and like I said the feedback that I got
from the uh first interview was just
terrific man um it's made me so more
aware
it made me feel so much better about
myself knowing that not only am I
helping myself
but I'm also helping somebody else who
might have who might have went through
the same thing that I went through
um it's a beautiful thing man
um I've been non-stop since the last
interview I did I've been non-stop I've
been to Hawaii
um
I got I have five children I have four
girls and a son
um and my oldest daughter
she's the biggest she's a beautician to
the Stars
um and she lives in Hawaii she has her
own shop
and uh I got back in contact with her
after the first interview I got in
contact with my other kids I hadn't been
in contact with him for a minute but all
my kids know of me and know who I am
and love me unconditionally
and she flew me to Hawaii I stayed there
two months she lives on the island of
Hilo on the big island
um
man you've been clean now for how long
almost 13 months 13 months almost 13
months from crack right from crack
alcohol all that
all that
and you know what's so
amazing about it it's not even as hard
as I thought it was going to be
I just kept putting up the wall because
I think at the time
when I was going through what I was
going through
I didn't know how to really
look forward
till tomorrow
because some of the times I didn't
expect to see tomorrow
you know so when I was doing what I was
doing I was just going at a full board
full board
yeah I was going at a full board and um
it was just um
it was upsetting but
you know thinking about
where I came from
and where I am right now
it's the difference between night and
day because
I also want to thank you Mark for giving
me the opportunity to come
and open up and tell my story because
that's what I needed
because the problems
uh and all the disappointment and all
the confusions I was going through I
kept inside
and it kept just getting boggled and
boggled and boggled and boggled and I
kept trying to um
to numb to numb To None to numb because
I didn't want to feel
um but it's okay today to feel
you know I'm not embarrassed uh about
what I went through because I look at it
as a learning experience
um and sometimes you have to go through
what you have to go through to get to
where you need to be
um like I said in the last interview
it's all experienced man
it's just about
somewhere deep down inside of me when I
was in my madness I wanted to get out
I wanted to get out it was certain
certain things that I wouldn't do
some I did a lot of weird stuff but it
was certain things that I wouldn't do
because I've always had that
that mindset even in way way way in the
back of my mind
to change to change this is not who I am
this is not who my mind raised me to be
this is not what my mom would want me to
be my mom is probably really looking for
in her grave if she if she knew what I
was doing right now
um and I could have reached out
the family members family members were
looking for me
um not knowing my whereabouts uh not
knowing my well-being
um but for some reason I was just so
wrapped up
so wrapped up in my own little world
that I caged myself
and um it was a struggle Mark I can't
even sugar coat it it was a struggle and
a half to get back just to get back
because like I said I went in and out of
programs in and out of programs I went
to the programs for the right reasons
but I left the programs for all the
wrong reasons because I was up here
I was up here and I've come to realize
that being in your mind is like a crime
scene it's all taped off up there
you know nothing good comes from your
mind
if you're not willing to live what you
speak
so that's what I've been doing
you know I try to let my yes be yes my
no be no my right be right my wrong be
wrong
so
there's a lot of things still going on
in my life but it's easier to manage
it's easier to control it's easier to
live with because my whole mindset has
changed my belief has changed a thousand
percent
I believe that I can be the best friend
that I can be just being who I am
I don't have to do anything specific
I don't have to jump through hoops to
try to prove to people that have changed
I don't do any of that only thing I do
is wake up in the morning I stay prayed
up you know and I go about my day in a
positive sense
and I get positive results
um
oh yeah I got my tea you see I got my
teeth uh
you look good yeah thank you I couldn't
get
um The Fosters because I felt like this
I was like well
if I get the parcels
the parcels they were kind of expensive
but some kind of way out I could
probably
squeezed it in and afforded it but I was
like no why do that when
the posters are going to look brand new
and my remaining teeth are not going to
look so brand new
so I was like well you know it
I'm starting everything I know I'm
starting everything you know so
I had all my teeth pulled
um and I had to uh
you know just manage you know these are
Dentures yeah waiting on my dentures and
it was cool mark
because um
that never stopped me from being who I
am I would go around people and didn't
have any any teeth in my mouth and be
smiling have a good time and and and
it's it's so amazing
how people understand
because a lot of people that I know the
people that know me know my struggle
so me coming around and not having any
teeth was not a problem it was just they
just wanted me there because
by me having to wait for my dentures it
didn't change my personality
because like I said I've always been a
good guy
I just made bad decisions
so
I mean man my life is complete 360. and
and and I'm gonna say once again man
it's so many I got so many uplifting
loving concerning
feedback
from the swu family man it was great and
I look at my phone almost every other
day because one person left a comment
she was like Wayne whenever you're in a
dark place just look at these comments
so that's what I do that's what I do
whenever I feel like
I'm not having a good day I'll just get
my phone
and go to it and just read all the
comments right back on track
it's just as simple as that it's so
beautiful
yeah yeah it's it's oh man it's amazing
and you know it just gives me
more Drive
more drive because
they let me know I'm doing the right
thing even though I already know I'm
doing the right thing but it's just so
uplifting and amazing to have people in
your corner that don't even know you
these people don't know me from a hole
in the wall you know but they
they recognize they recognize with me
and they
um how can I say
they understand yeah 90 of the
commenters on my channel yeah are so
compassionate empathetic God oh my God
it was I was like wow it was so amazing
and the best thing you can ever do for
yourself in your life if you're going
through any kind of turmoil any kind of
Injustice
are you just confused in your own mind
talk about it
that's why when somebody approached me
about coming to do the first interview
Mark I was skeptical because I was like
well what are people going to think
about me
you know if I tell them
all all the horrible things that I've
done
all horrible things I've been through
I said Well it can't be no worse than me
continuing to kill myself
it's either going to make me better
or it's not going to do anything at all
because it couldn't get no worse than
what I was already doing you're living
on the streets no actually I was in the
program
but but you've been living on the
streets oh yeah so your your past is
you're you're on the streets
oh man I smoke crack 20 plus years
20 plus years
you weren't around for the kids because
uh early on in their life because
when I first uh started smoking crack it
wasn't on a continual basis it was every
now and then I grew up every now and
then and then it grew it grew it grew
until we just you think the crack
addiction
stemmed from the child abuse oh yeah
most definitely the alcohol the drinking
all of that because like I said
I had nobody to talk to I I had been
wanting to tell
people what was going on with me but I
didn't know how they were going to feel
about me how old are you and uh I was
um
when I first was able to really kind of
understand what I was feeling
and wanted to tell somebody that's when
my mom passed
that's when my mom passed
and then after that I was like well you
know what I should have
I should have told my mom early on
because I was ready when it was
happening
um I was I think it first started out
because I was around four four or five
who was it it was my father
he was my father
um
and like I said he stuck his finger in
my rectum and
it just hurts so bad I bled all that
I didn't I didn't know what was
happening I didn't know why was
happening I didn't understand why it was
happening from who it came from what
kind of dad does that [ __ ] it's crazy
that's
yeah that's what I was trying to figure
out and then you still want to come
around
you know and act uh like everything's
okay
try to give me money I would even take
the money no more I didn't really want
to see them
you know and I think he on I think he
kind of felt it
but it's like he didn't care you know
because he was alcoholic
he was alcoholic
um I think my I don't I wouldn't say my
mom was an alcoholic to a certain extent
because
she got her life together once I burned
the house down
uh and almost took her alive
uh so after that my mom completely
stopped drinking how'd you burn that
how'd you burn the house down um
I took matches
I never forget it
I was mad at her because she didn't
because she came in and she fell out and
went to sleep and I had to watch my baby
brother's sister
I didn't want to watch my baby brother
and sister I wanted to go outside
but I couldn't wake her up so I just
struck matches
and threw them in the trash can
and once the house once once the trash
can caught on fire
I ran out the house but before I did
that my brother and sister had already
went around the country's Market just
live right on the corner
so my little brother had took my little
sister over there
and um you know I was still upset and
didn't understand because I don't know
why for the life of me I held my mother
responsible
for my fault my father did to me I don't
understand why I did that but only thing
I can only
um logical conclusions that I could come
to is that I thought that she should
understand that she should know anytime
something like that or anything happens
too much because I changed
I changed um
and it's like I don't know if she
noticed or not I think
um she probably thought I was losing my
mind that's probably what it was she
thought it was good because my mother
was old school
my mother was old school my mother was
36 years old when she had me 38 but she
had my little brother 41 when she had my
little sister
so my mother became a mother late in her
life
um
but you know it it it's crazy how life
works
it's crazy how life works because I
think life is not for you to understand
life is for you to learn from
because each day
is a learning experience
no day is the same
it might look the same it might feel the
same as yesterday but something in today
is going to be different from yesterday
um so that's
that's what I I hang my head on
something today is going to be different
tomorrow
so if I keep in my right mind if I stay
the course stay grounded stay focused
I'll recognize the change
and I look at the changes blessings
because anytime I can wake up in the
morning
I haven't smoked no dope I haven't
talked crazy nobody having disrespected
nobody I haven't gotten fight with
anybody I haven't tore up anybody's
property I haven't disrespected anybody
anything like that it's a win-win
so I just take that and I build each day
I build I build I keep going because I
let who I am
shine and the only way I can do that is
keep my belief in God strong it has to
be that I pray and all day
as long as I'm awake I pray if I'm going
to the store I'm like thank you Jesus I
don't I'm not going to buy a beer thank
you God I'm not going to buy dope thank
you God I'm not going to disrespect to
cheat on my girl you know it's it's
those kind of little things that you
recognize
on a continual basis
um setting gratitude oh yeah most
definitely I am so grateful oh my God
I can even start to tell you how
grateful I am and
it's like
I still ask myself every day I was like
Wayne
why did you wait so long
to finally understand
but I don't dwell on it because it took
What it Took oh dear I'm 63.
I'll be 64 in August
um it took What it Took
for me to go through what I had to go
through to get to where I need to be it
took all of that to get to this point
and then
you know I don't question God you know
one day that one day the guys is a
thousand years to us
so
I think
because if you think about it you only
get one life
you only get one life and I think that's
why God gives you free will
you get to understand and get to go
through things
to learn who you are and uplift yourself
and
kind of recognize
uh
what kind of person would you need to be
or what you want to be or or your belief
system you know so
it's it's funny because
I'm not I'm not a bible thumper
or anything of that nature but I read it
some things I don't understand because
everything is in Parables but
God kind of guides you and gives you
insight
on the things you need to do
everything you need to do needs to be
good
you know
um
as good as you can be but you have to be
good within yourself
that's what I've been doing Mark I feel
so good man I feel so good I feel so
blessed you know
um
I'm going back to Hawaii in February
uh
I have another daughter that I just
reconnected with
um like four months ago
she thought I was dead
so me and my daughter my first daughter
in Hawaii we got
on the computer we looked her up
and we found her and she lives in Vegas
she's doing great
um my baby brother my baby sister doing
great I have grandkids oh my God man
life is just
it's just wonderful I mean I had my good
days and I had my bad days but I don't
use
I had my good days and my Badness but I
don't disrespect myself I had my good
days and my bad days but I don't respect
anybody else
I don't
let what I used to do
get in the way of what I'm trying to do
I just keep it simple man I keep it
simple I just put one foot in front of
the other one and stay in my Lane
I don't
look for anybody's
um how can I say
I don't look for anybody's clarification
other things I do because the things I'm
doing
it's just ordinary normal stuff
you know
I do with ordinary normal people do
ordinary normal people get up and go to
work
they take care of their families
they take care of yourself
you know they take care of their
business they pay their rent they pay
their bills
you know they feed they self they make
sure the house is foot is full of food
and all the bills are paid that's normal
stuff it's nothing outrageous it's just
normal stuff
so
I'm just coming back to the normality of
what I'm supposed to do and just being
me
and um
man it's just things are just happening
so this just happening so fast for me
sometimes I have to slow down and say
whoa
I have to sort stuff out because
all the things that I'm doing now
were promised to me
as far as I guess my blessings
but by me being in my old experience I
couldn't I was blocking all my blessings
with all the things that all the
horrible things I was doing using being
under influence so when my blessings
were coming to me I couldn't recognize
what they were because I
I wasn't all there
so now I get to see
understand and feel
what it is to be normal
you know uh even when I was in my
madness Mark I used to sometimes just be
so tired I used to just sit down
anywhere and just watch people and I
would see people taking their kids to
school
people going back to about their
business they're going to work they're
going in store just simply buying a
water
or buying a soda I couldn't even do that
I was like man this is crazy what is
wrong with me
I have more sense than I ought to have
more intelligence than I should need why
am I sitting here
broke discussed it and can't be trusted
when I can't even go by a sip of 35 soda
but I just spent
15 or 1600 on crack
you know alcohol didn't even buy a
burger
it was just crazy man
so all those things all those
experiences always stuck with me so I
thought myself to the nail day after day
after day after day after day
slowly be shoulder bit by bit I was
trying to fight back I was trying to
claw back to get back to the real world
and I'm just so thankful and grateful
that God didn't let me down my madness
you know and that was one of my um
I was one of my um
my
um
my questions too because I was wondering
I was like
if I die today
how am I going to look in the casket
because I was I'm 260 pounds now
I was one probably
180 at the most soaking wet when I was
using
I was three to four Shades Darker
you can see all my bones my my eyes were
sunk back in my head
I was like wow if something happened to
me today
it would be so embarrassing for my
children and for my family
to have to bury me you know in that
condition and then the cold part about
it is I used to always know that people
will come to your funeral
and say oh my God Lois that's my baby
sister's name you put your brother away
so nice it was the funeral was so
beautiful but then they're saying the
same breath but he sure look bad
you know what I'm saying things like
that
that always is always right there in my
mind
so I just kept fighting more I just kept
fighting how'd you get clean
um is it program
yes yes it was the program
but I think it was more so me just
praying how long was the program
um when I first came I was in the
program 46 days
I left the program
and went home because I had Financial
business set to take care of and
everything
from that is doing very well
um
so I left the program
but I'm still affiliated
with the uh with the program I still go
to meetings I still have a sponsor I
still
um uh read the big book I do everything
I don't do what I'm I want to do Mark
how much I do what I'm supposed to do
because I know what the other side looks
like the other side ain't gonna never
change it's not gonna never change that
was a big misconception in my life
because I always think well you know
what
I can go back and do because last time
they weren't doing so good but this time
they might be doing good
chickeration your mind would
your mind will steer you wrong every
time so I heard somebody say the meaning
don't listen to your thoughts because
your mind is a crime scene it's all
taped off up there especially being an
ex-atic
I don't trust anything I think
that's why I continuously do what I'm
supposed to do
when I do what I'm supposed to do the
results that I get
get me joy
give me peace give me understanding
because my mind would tell me oh it's
okay go get a beer
or go ahead go hit a joint you ain't got
to smoke no crack just go hit a joints
you'll be okay
but the reality of my experience tells
me that I can't do none of that
because it's all a setup
it's all the setup so anybody who's
ever been in the drugs or under
influential drugs or indulgent drugs and
knows exactly what I'm talking about
so I don't even think about anything
like that it runs across my mind but
that's all it is is a thought
it comes and it goes
well what do you think the biggest
Factor was in you getting clean
my belief changing not spending two or
three months in a program but yeah the
way you see yourself the way because
I've always like I said I've never been
a dumb person by any aspect I've always
been intelligent I know right from wrong
so
that's why I said earlier
I do as speak
I say what I say and I do what I say
I say I'm not going to get high today I
don't get high I'm not going to buy beer
today I don't buy beer I'm not going to
smoke crack today I don't smoke crack
I'm not going to disrespect myself or my
girl or anybody else and I don't do that
you know
I speak what I do into existence I no
longer do depend on my mind
you know because
and and by living like that I have no I
have no down time it's just so much
going on in my my phone's constantly
ringing constantly ringing people are
checking in with me things are going on
events are happening
we're going shopping I just want to
spend over 600 on clothes
I was amazed I was [ __ ] amazed I was
like whoa and I go into the stores and
I'm more I don't look at Price tags
I used to do that when I was using them
if I had twenty dollars I'd go in the
store I said well I ain't gonna get that
because it's going to take away from my
crack money
Don't Smoke Crack anymore I don't smoke
weed I don't drink I don't do this I go
about I want
I don't look at the price tag
if I say
I'm going to spend four hundred dollars
I can look at everything I buy and
calculate everything that I'm spending
and once I get to maybe 350 375 I'll
pipe down because I know there's taxes
on everything I buy
you know I'm saying simple stuff
simple stuff like that
is so rewarding it's so rewarding
um but you have to you just have to get
it out anything that's plaguing you down
anything that's holding you down
anything that's done your growth get
that [ __ ] out of you man I tell
everybody
I tell everybody
people that I first meet I met somebody
in Hawaii
uh one of my one of my daughter's
clients husbands uh and I went with my
daughter
to to her house to do it my daughter's
doing her hair and me and her husband
was talking and I just told me your mama
ex drug addict I did this I I'm just
running up and I didn't care mark
I didn't care I freed myself whenever I
can
because it's not it's not what you do
it's how you do it and do you know Mark
after talking to him and telling him my
experiences and all the things that I
went through do you know he told me in
the same way if you say guess what I
used to be extra drug addict too I smoke
crack it's like what
but by me opening up to him and letting
him know who I was I think he felt
comfortable enough to let me know who he
was
and I think I was over there with my
daughter about four and a half hours
because my daughter were doing break
doing braids and the lady's hair and we
stopped we talked Non-Stop
Non-Stop and we never talked about the
same thing twice
he's a writer he took me into his
writing room and showed me all the books
it was amazing it was amazing so
that's those are some of the rewards
that you can look forward to
when you just open up to people
don't be ashamed or don't be afraid of
your experience because your experience
can springboard you
into a whole lot of things that you're
worth
you know um I haven't been broke
since the day I walked into that program
I haven't been broke I haven't had a lot
of money but I'm not broke I have not I
have yet to not have cigarettes if I
want to buy soda hamburger cheeseburger
chili fries steak whatever I want I can
do that
and it's so rewarding more I can call
anybody in my phone right now if I need
anything and it's there
it's there it's there they don't ask me
what I need it for they trust you now
they trust me
they trust me only because I trust
myself
you know I trust myself
and I know it's not me
that's making this possible it's all God
it's all God I have to trust and believe
that God is going to guide me and direct
me to be to not only be who I want to be
but to be who he wants me to be
you know so that's why I say
God wants me to be good he wants me to
be trustworthy he wants me to be honest
he wants me to have integrity he wants
me to help people and just with my story
you know and the feedback I got from the
viewers oh my God it was man I cried
I cried when I first saw and I got over
91 000 views I cry I read every one of
them I cried
um
because some of these things that people
were telling me that they were going
through that was similar to what I was
going through and how me opening up and
and telling my story and freeing myself
uh wanted to let them free theyself
you know
um a lot of people were saying a lot of
things that they held on and held on to
inside and they want to talk to people
but we're going to be stereotyped
so they keep it inside and it's just
it's
like a cancer man it's like a cancer
so to the viewers I just want to say
thank you guys from the bottom of my
heart thank you guys for inviting my
heart I read your comments every day
I do sometimes I'll be at home
and it could be maybe 9 30 10 o'clock
I'll try to be asleep maybe between
somewhere between 11 11 30. and so I'll
just turn the TV off and just get my
phone
is looking at it and just my first
interview and just started reading the
comments
reading the comments and it brings a
warmth
and a peace and a joy over me because
I'm not in this alone
you know there are people all over the I
had people from
um for Toronto Canada
uh
uh
Australia
if I was like oh my God
really I was like and it just gave me a
sense of purpose it gave me
it gave me so much strength and so much
motivation
to keep doing
what I'm doing that's why I said I got
to get back in contact with Marcus I
want to come back and do a follow-up
because it's just so refreshing for me
to let people see that if you keep
believing in yourself
keep God first you second in your
situation A change but you have to
change your mindset I have to believe
every day on a continual basis
that I'm going to be better than I was
I'm going to be better tomorrow than I
was today I have to believe that I can
change
so if I say if I believe I can change
the things I do will show the change in
me I don't have to explain it to anybody
you know
my girl is fine everything is good I
remember when I was in when I was in my
addiction as soon as I walked out the
door she'd be calling my phone where you
at
she don't do that no more
I go where I want to go she don't call
me none of that and I could she's the
only thing she has she said what time
are you coming back
I say if I'm going to if I'm coming to
LA from Antelope Valley to visit or if
I'm going to San Fernando Valley the
village of my sister if I leave at 10 in
the morning let's say I'll be back about
six at night
six in the evening and that's when I'm
back
not 601
not 602
5 30 5 45 Maybe
closest I could is five minutes to six
because I leave on time everything I do
is on a schedule
it's not about me no more
I got kids I got responsibilities
I'm in a relationship you know uh I got
people who believe in me
you know and the viewers believe in me
and you guys don't know it's all about
you guys I appreciate you guys so much
God bless you guys
um and I wish I could meet every one of
y'all on an individual basis we could
have a great time we could have a
thousand things to talk about the
positivity brings more positivity it is
oh my God oh my God and the negativity
yeah negativity Breeze negativity
positive debris positivity and that's
who I surround myself with I have family
members who drink I have family members
who smoke I have family members who get
high I have family members who shoot
heroin I have family members to do all
this stuff
but I don't knock them I don't look down
on them about what they do but do I hang
out with them no
no if I go to a family function I see
them do I hang out with them no
hey how you doing coach give him a Dap
or whatever and I'm over here
we ain't nobody doing that
you know and right then and there
they're not doing it at that particular
moment but that's what they do
so
I can't keep going to the barber shop
not expecting to get a haircut
so if I drop my focus or drop my guards
and start hanging out I'm going to be
telling myself it's okay to hang out
with what was killing me
you know what I'm saying so I have to
always keep that in mind so that's why I
stay prayed up and it's not about being
better than anybody it's not about
Downing anybody or trying to
I would do anybody and make anybody look
bad I have to care about myself
I have to care about myself first
because it's about me
it's about my life
and
you see that sound right there
I was scared of that I was scared of
that because I've heard those sirens and
seen those Sirens come and pick up some
of my best friends and I was like oh
Lord I don't want that to be me
that's why a lot of things
that crossed my mind and my addiction
I was like nope I'm not gonna do that
one because that's going to have me in
one of those right there
I said if I'm gonna be in one of those
it's going to be by my own fruition
I'm not going to do nothing to nobody to
have nobody else take my life
you know and I was just lucky God just
had his hand on me
all those years
all those years and I always knew God
existed I always knew he was there
but I was just selfish
key key thing in life you if you're
selfish
you got to stop that
you got to break that cycle my mother
used to always tell me
if you think you can live in this world
by yourself and don't need other
people's help you got one foot in the
grave and other phenomenal banana peel
just that simple
everybody needs somebody
I'm not afraid to ask anybody for what I
need if it's just advice
you know that's why
when someone told me about this about
you Mark and I like I said once again I
want to thank you so much for what you
do man what you do because
you are such a big part
of who I am right now I tell everybody
about you I do I tell everybody about
you
um and people tell me oh I want I want
to go and um
and talk and talk about what things that
are holding me down but I'm embarrassed
I say [ __ ] doing what you're doing is is
embarrassing because you
when you're using
getting high
whatever you're doing if you think
people don't know what you're doing
you're sadly mistaken
people see you people talk
I used to think back in the day when I
was in my addiction well okay I'm not
going to get high on this side of town
I'm gonna go way on the west side and
get high
but you have to remember people who
don't use go places they got jobs they
go but they know people people know them
people know you people that you don't
know but they know you they know you're
akin to certain people and they see you
when you think nobody else sees you they
see you and they related message do you
know I've had so many of my uh family
members tell me Wayne
one of my friends told me she saw you
way on the west side over there smoking
I was like no I went she's like yes you
were because the people she was buying
stuff from is her cousins
all those are life lessons
all this is life stuff
so when we think we can keep whatever
we're doing in the dark
a lot of people know what you're doing
but they just don't say anything to you
about it because of the way you're going
to receive it that's a that's a that's
another big achievement in my life too
you can tell me anything I don't
perceive it in a negative way
because I've been there because the
things that you're telling me is the
truth
people tell me wait man when you was
getting high you was you was you was
like this and you was like that I was
like yeah I was crazy as [ __ ] I was I
was insane
you know and I appreciate it because
that lets me know that people were
watching me
people wanted the best for me they would
say when I'm so glad that you're not who
you used to be I say she was you glad
I'm ecstatic
um and we talk you know
once you free yourself
from the bondage of you
there's nothing you could go through
that could be more embarrassing than
what you've already been through and
people who love you people who care
about you people who want the best for
you I show up
they'll understand
like I said I can call anybody right now
and I can get what I want there won't be
no questions asked I can walk out of my
house my girl don't ask me where I'm
going I've came all over my little belly
up here my phone never rang that once
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in all this
Trust
you have to trust
that God loves you you have to trust
that there is a God you have to trust
that you can be better than what you
experiencing
you have to trust people
you have to trust
your instinct because I'm
even in your Madness mark
your common sense never stops working
your common sense never shuts off
your common sister tell you
okay you got twenty dollars in your
pocket you should go buy you something
to eat or you should go buy you some
water you should go buy you some
cosmetics and go somewhere and wash it
up
that's your common sense
but then you're Insanity take all that
away and have you out there trying to
kill yourself
so you have to trust the instincts
um and I just have to trust Mark I have
to trust myself more than anything
I've stressed myself morning and trust
my um
I have to trust my integrity
you know I have to keep my Integrity
first
I don't steal
I see people walking down street people
and Josh stuff hey excuse me
website the other day I was in the store
and the lady dropped forty dollars I
said hey Miss ma'am you dropped that
she's like oh my God thank you thank you
oh me
integrity
little thing when you when you trust
yourself and you trust the process
of the ruins of n a a and CA and you
trust
the process
your thinking changes remember that
first interview I said the first person
has to do my thinking has to change
that's the first and foremost your
thinking has to change you have to come
out of the darkness and flip back into
the light
it's not going to Blind you
it's not going to burn you
you know you're not gonna you're not
gonna burst into a ball of flyer if you
come back to you if you come back to who
you are
I think the only thing that that blessed
me more to come back and to this point
is that even though I was going through
what I was going through I didn't know
who I was but I was curious to find out
who I could be
all right Wayne well thank you so much
for sharing your story hey man I
appreciate it thank you so much for
having me thank you viewers for blessing
me I love you guys you guys keep the
comments coming because I'ma read
everyone you guys are with me every day
I appreciate you thank you amazing thank
you you're welcome
I know